yesterday was the one year anniversary
of the january 6 trump riots joe biden
the president spoke to the country
yesterday morning and it was without
question the best speech joe biden has
ever given now whether you think that
there was a low standard or a high
standard for that it doesn't really
matter it was by far the best speech
that he has given as president the
energy the fire
where has it been until now almost like
a completely different biden and we're
going to look at the speech the speech
was immediately called divisive by fox
news which to me means joe biden did a
really good job of placing blame for the
january 6 riots of 2021 exactly where
they belong at the feet of donald trump
to a great degree
let's just jump right into the first
segment
what did we not see
we didn't see a former president
who had just rallied the mob to attack
sitting in the private dining room off
the oval office in the white house
watching it all on television right and
doing nothing
for hours
as police were assaulted
lives at risk
the nation's capital under siege
this wasn't a group of tourists
this was an armed insurrection
they weren't looking to uphold the will
of the people they were looking to deny
the will of the people true they were
looking uphold they weren't looking
uphold a free and fair election they
were looking to overturn one
they were looking to save
the cause of america
they were looking to subvert the
constitution
this isn't about being bogged down in
the past
it's about making sure the past isn't
buried
that's the only way forward
that's what great nations do
they don't bury the truth
they face up to it sounds like hyperbole
but that's the truth they face up to it
we are a great nation
my fellow americans
in life there's truth
and tragically there are lies
lies conceived and spread
for profit
and power
we must be absolutely clear about what
is true
and what is a lie
and here's the truth
the former president of the united
states of america
has created and spread a web of lies
about the 2020 election
he's done so because he values power
over principle
because he sees his own interest
is more important than his country's
interest than america's interest
and because his bruised ego
matters more to him than our democracy
or our constitution
he can't accept he lost
very very well said and we'll look at a
couple of other moments here joe biden
saying
are we going to be a country that
accepts political violence
or are we going to be a country that
rejects that which is the fundamental
question when we think back to these
riots
and so at this moment
we must decide
what kind of nation are we going to be
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm
are we going to be a nation
will we allow partisan election
officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
these are the fundamental questions one
year in and the reason that they're
fundamental as much as right-wingers
want to say
the left is making such a big deal like
people like ben shapiro were saying the
riots were bad but the people who did it
have been punished it wasn't an
insurrection there was no chance it was
going to steal an election well the
question is what will happen in 2022
what will happen in 2024 what if the
generals that wrote the retired generals
who wrote that up that i talked about on
monday saying
if the military were on the side of the
coup
it actually could happen what about that
and joe biden also during the speech
laying out what it was that happened on
january 6th phony partisan audits were
undertaken
long after the election in several
states
none
changed the results
and in some of them the irony is the
margin of victory actually grew slightly
so let's speak plainly about what
happened in 2020
even before the first ballot was cast
the former president was preemptively
showing doubt about the election results
true
he built his lie over months
wasn't basing any facts
he was just looking for an excuse a
pretext
to cover for the truth
he's not just a former president
he's a defeated former president
and we will actually talk about trump's
reaction to this a little bit later but
first we are just following the joe
biden speech
joe biden pointing out something i've
been talking about for years which is
you know these people's stated
principles
which they abandon as soon as they're
inconvenient
the same applies to the law says joe
biden you can't just abide in the law
when you don't like it
you can't love your country only when
you win
you can't obey the law only when it's
convenient
you can't be patriotic when you embrace
and enable lies
those who storm this capital
and those who instigated and incited
and those who called on them to do so
held a dagger at the throat of america
at american democracy
the best speech i have seen joe biden
give as president and here he is uh just
winding it down this is the last clip
we'll look at and listen to authority in
this nation will always
be peacefully transferred
i believe the power of the presidency
and the purpose is to unite this nation
not divide it so lift us up
not tear us apart
it's about us
about us
not about me
deep in the heart of america burns
aflame lived almost 250 years ago
of liberty freedom and equality
this is not a land of kings or dictators
or autocrats
we're a nation of laws of order not
chaos of peace not
violence here in america the people rule
through the ballot
and their will prevails
so let us remember together
we're one nation
under god
indivisible
that today
tomorrow
and forever at our best we are the
united states of america so joe biden
ending the speech as he often does but a
very very good speech
the right calling it divisive the right
saying it was not a uniting speech and
it is all typical of the right
to say that calling out the divisive
actions of a year ago is divisive seeing
racism is racist this is the same trope
that they've been pulling for a while
very nicely done by joe biden doesn't
change anything about his effectiveness
as a legislator
or getting getting legislation passed
but this was a very good speech and part
of the reason you know it was good is it
so triggered the former president donald
trump
donald trump within
minutes and hour of joe biden's brutal
speech
condemning his inciting of the trump
riots a year ago yesterday published a
statement riddled with random
capitalization
and lies and all of the things we have
come accustomed to seeing from the
former president let's take a look at
that statement donald trump saying quote
biden who is destroying our nation with
insane policies of open capital b
borders corrupt capital e elections
disastrous energy policies
unconstitutional mandates and
devastating school closures
used my name today to try to further
divide america
this political theater
is all just a distraction from the fact
biden has completely and totally failed
our capital c country no longer has
capital b borders that's not true has
totally and completely lost control of
covet record numbers
we are seeing record numbers the world
is is no longer capital e i energy
independent capital i inflation is
rampant our capital m military is in
chaos and our exit or surrender from
afghanistan was perhaps the most
embarrassing day in the long and
distinguished history of the united
states and so much more remember that
trump had no better plan for afghanistan
whenever we got out it was going to be
chaos at least joe biden got us out as
i've said before
why is it that the unselect committee of
totally pardoned partisan political
hacks whose judgment has long ago been
made not discussing the rigged
presidential election of 2020
because it wasn't rigged and it's not
their charge that's not what the
committee is doing
it's because they don't have the answers
or justifications for what happened says
trump they got away with something and
it is leading to our capital c countries
destruction they all want they want all
conversation concerning the capital e
election capital c cancelled just look
at the numbers they speak for themselves
they are not justifiable so the
complicit media just calls it the big
lie when in actuality the big lie was
the capital e election itself as many
instances of out and out lying here
about biden's policy
uh
and all of these other things
as much as there is random
capitalization donald trump highly
highly triggered which suggests to me
that joe biden really hit a nerve it was
the right decision
for trump to cancel his press conference
yesterday because as triggered as he was
i can only imagine he would have
completely humiliated himself had he
actually taken questions from reporters
so that is it
biden on the one year anniversary of the
riots and trump on the one year
anniversary of the riots we're going to
take a quick break uh find me on twitter
at d pacman we will be right back make
sure you grab yourself a membership at
joinpackman.com you'll get access to the
award-winning bonus show these are all
awards we've created but they are awards
also you'll get commercial free audio
and video streams of the show you can
sign up at joinpacman.com
let's get back to the phones after a
multi-week hiatus
due to various federal holidays and
different things and reasons and all of
that sort of stuff we now do calls via
discord davidpakman.com
slash discord
let's start today with i i can't see
is it kendall from is it san marino or
somewhere in california kendall
actually it's uh san marcos texas san
marcos de okay that's still allowed
that's okay
um yeah hey david so my question is i
have a friend who identifies as a
conservative republican okay but she's
not she's not like
those the nowadays republicans who are
very cult-like and all that stuff and i
can have i can have meaningful
conversations with her and when i
introduced her to my sister afterward
after my friend had left my sister who
was very liberal told me to stop being
friends with her
solely based on the fact she is a
conservative republican how would i how
do you think i should handle that
situation because i don't want to make
my friend mad and lose my friend but i
also don't want to piss off my sister
who's been my best friend forever well
so let's i mean the devil is in the
details really do they do your sister
and your friend live in close proximity
to each other where you would be seeing
them together
uh yeah especially recently i'm uh
graduating uh i'm graduating from texas
state uh university soon and there's
going to be a lot of upcoming events
where both of them are going to be
in close proximity well i think you need
to decide
do you want to go to your sister and
just have a conversation and say listen
sis i love you i want to have a
relationship with you i also have i'm an
adult i have other friends
and this is not some you know disgusting
immoral person it's just kind of i'm
hearing from you this is just kind of
like a
you know basic conservative and i find
her to be a good person good enough for
me to be friends i want all of us to be
able to be adults here and and see what
the reaction is the other possibility
would be to accept maybe cutting off one
or the other which i don't particularly
recommend i don't think it's at the
point where that needs to happen but
it's up to you to determine how far you
want to go with this you know i can't
it's hard for me to tell you
okay i just wanted i just wanted some
advice from uh someone who whose whole
job is politics yeah i mean i would my
instinct not knowing nearly enough about
you or your friend or your sister or the
dynamic would be
to go to your sister and just be very
frank and be like listen if this was
some lunatic racist
trumpist whatever
i wouldn't be friends with them and you
should be doing an intervention if i
were but that's not what this is this is
just someone who's kind of like your
milktoast conservative and we don't
agree on things but uh this is still a
friend of mine and i want us to all be
able to be together and uh i hope that
you would respect that as my sister and
see where it goes that's my that would
be my first step
okay well thank you so much david my
pleasure good let us know how it goes
okay kendall
i will you have a good day all right
there is kendall
from texas what a situation let's go
next to isa from london issa you were on
the air
hey david
i'm doing well
um cool cool um uh you may have seen
this did you see the louisiana judge who
was uh came under fire because she was
caught uh using racial slurs on her home
camera and then she ended up resigning i
did see it yeah
um i went to i want to ask i feel like
you know looking into the uk into the us
sorry from the outside i feel like
it's kind of a simulation to the point
where
would it be crazy to think that she
might run for some kind of local
political office now
no i mean you know obviously the
narrative is she's been canceled you
know she wow she was caught saying
something in the privacy of her own home
and now it's been used to force her into
resigning you know the truth is as a
judge
um you regularly have to make
a decisions that are
critical life-altering decisions for
people that come before you in the court
and if there is any reason to believe
that on racial grounds you might be
assigning different sentences or
evaluating cases evidence differently
emotions
that's a major major problem you know
you could
i would stipulate
that there are some jobs where you might
be a lunatic racist and it really might
not make a difference you know if you
work in uh
i don't even know if you i don't want to
diminish any any profession but if it's
a profession where you kind of work by
yourself if you work in meat processing
and your job is to
you know scale salmon or something like
that and you basically work by yourself
on the production line you're and you're
a lunatic racist yeah it might be hard
to relate to the workers that are of a
different race but it's not like part of
your job if you're scaling salmon if
that makes sense whereas if you're a
judge this is your beliefs about race
are so important now you could make the
case well despite using the racial slurs
she's not actually racist but
you're in a position where the stakes
are really really high so but to your
point despite it being completely
reasonable what took place yeah she
might be the type of person that's made
a hero by the right and ends up running
for public office
yeah yeah i know
100 i i
completely agree with what you said
about the uh you know uh if you have
some other kind of job
but i feel like stuff like this has
happened in the past and it's kind of
led these people to snap and kind of tip
them over the edge and then they become
like full blown right wing but yes i was
thinking even if if she did run for
office she could probably base like her
whole campaign i guess around
first amendment or free speech rights
being violated or whatever you know 100
you you you have your finger on the
pulse of the culture wars for sure that
could be her entire candidacy i was
canceled but i'm back
yeah yeah no exactly uh hey look even if
she doesn't want for office
you know maybe
700k a year drop a fox as an analyst or
something about how the election was
stolen no that'll be cushy that'll be
cushy for sure hey listen how are things
in london with omicron
oh yeah it's raging it's raging man
definitely have you had them
no i've fortunately i mean i've done uh
all the tests i've done come back
negative but
uh the daily sort of i guess new cases
show up to about 200k that's the highest
there have been the deaths haven't been
rising too much kind of been at this the
same level yeah between 100 and 200 a
day but yeah cases cases have shown up
definitely
is the hope there as it is here that
this way wave will come and go with many
cases but relatively few deaths and then
maybe we can move on
well yeah definitely yeah yeah 100 but
the thing is uh that we haven't really
had any restrictions either right and um
you know i i work at a university i work
in research and i got an email today
saying you know we want to try and
maximize in-person
campus teaching campus work and whatnot
so yep kind of just getting on with it
really yeah
all right well very good are our chip
shops mostly still open
uh yes they are okay and uh the fish is
still fresh and everything oh yeah it's
frying it's frying beautiful beautiful
all right issa thank you for the call
all right thanks david all right very
powerful testimony there as to the
situation with fish and chips in london
it's
a critical critical issue let's go next
to yusuf from our friendly neighbors to
the north in toronto canada yusuf you
were on the air
question it's slightly tongue-in-cheek
but also slightly serious um
oh you cut out right when we were gonna
get to the question i can tell your
connection is extremely shaky let's see
if we can back it up just a little bit
and take the question from the top
and he's gone
uh that's too bad i was looking forward
to hearing from yusuf let's go next to
tom from green bay wisconsin green bay
wisconsin welcome tom
tom from green bay you're on the air if
you unmute you will be able to talk to
me and i would love that
all right
tom from green bay i can see that you
were muted i've unmuted you but you are
you are self-muting if you unmute i will
be able to talk to you otherwise we will
have to move on
all right that's too bad i mean it's
like i can see that tom has not unmuted
which is sad let's try jamie from canada
jamie from canada you're on the air
hello
happy new year david thank you and we're
not on speakerphone are we
uh no we're not okay good it sounds like
we are but you can go ahead okay
oh wait uh
how does that sound does that sound
better it it sounds so much better i
can't even imagine what you were doing
before
oh i i i have this weird thing where i
need to plug in the usb microphone to my
laptop oh okay all right well go ahead
what's on your mind
uh i was wondering
you've probably been asked this question
before but why don't you ever run for
house or senate um that's the first part
of my question you know i have had
conversations with political consultants
about possible house seats to target and
i'm just not sure it's something i want
to do to be perfectly frank i don't know
that i could i i just don't know that
it's for me i don't know that i like the
idea of having to split time between
home and dc
i don't know that i want the kind of
financial oversight that's required for
like everything you do i i just am not
sure but when people have asked me i
i've not i've not ruled out anything but
for now there's not been a particular
seat that i've decided to target
uh okay um are you comfortable saying
what state you're in or is that personal
well at the time that these were
discussions it would have been
massachusetts
oh okay yeah
understandable also um second part of my
question i had this conversation with my
friends
uh back when the back in like at the
beginning of the year when the political
climb but was still like recovering now
hold on do you mean the beginning of
last year because it were five days the
beginning of 2021
beginning of 2021 that's what i meant
got it sorry i'm still trying to get
used to saying no i know last year yeah
yeah um to start at the beginning of
2021 around maybe march
um
we were talking after we were still
recovering from trump i i i mean i live
in canada and i was still like
traumatized by the election yeah um but
um
so we were talking about if not trump
who else because people are saying oh
trump could pick ron desantis instead of
uh using pence again because at that
time he was saying that pence had
betrayed him
multiple air quotes um but uh we were
also thinking about like uh we were
having this discussion on another server
and we were also thinking about like
maybe
nikki we were we were doing fantasy
pairing like nikki haley with marjorie
taylor green or something like that yeah
but yeah if not trump
who do you think
right now based on the polling i've seen
the only person who has a real shot is
ron desantis being the nominee
now it's we haven't even had the 2022
midterms yet anything could happen trump
could be dead by then everything could
completely change so i don't know but in
the polling i've seen
right now if it's if trump doesn't want
it and it seems trump would win a
primary
it would be desantis as the as the kind
of second second person which i think is
really scary because desantis is as much
trump as trump but less incompetent and
i think that that makes him more
dangerous
ah thank you but
it would also be
uh it'd also be interesting to see if he
ends up picking if it is trump the
front-runner if he ends up picking ron
desantis as his running mate that would
be i think that would be interesting it
would be fascinating i don't think trump
will do it and the reason why is over
the last six to nine months as we've
been covering there seems to be
increasing anger
from trump towards desantis that
desantis is getting attention so i
actually think for ego reasons trump
would not pick desantis
also i have no idea how to say i just
got re-elected it was like less than a
point yeah that last gubernatorial
election well he's up this year i
believe right so let's see what happens
yeah
hopefully and i and people are calling
me crazy but i think beta o'rourke's got
it uh if if the if the tide change is
just a teeny little bit and by people
are saying that i'm going to take away
your guns come it makes them unelectable
that's what people are saying i i am
concerned about that comment i'm
concerned about that okay well
thank you so much
david thank you so much likewise there's
jamie from canada getting a bunch of
important issues uh right on the table
and very very quickly i must say let's
go next to noble from salt lake city
utah noble you were on the air
david i'm a long time viewer how are you
i'm doing well
that's good
my question is more so why aren't people
on the left and the right like doing
overtures of olive branches and working
more so towards
economic
and um
and political change for the better than
they are right now
what's their incentive to do that
their incentive to do that against that
right now is mostly um culture war
issues but the incentive to do that
right now is more or less like um
living um
basically living standards being him
being met at least like health care
um or
or even scancillation of student debt or
hell even holding some
people in people who are in power for
accountable for fraud or
or whatever not okay so here's the
problem you're thinking about this as if
as if elected officials care primarily
about
i'm not asking uh people on in congress
no i'm asking ordinary people
oh uh i so so tell me exactly what the
vision is then so i mean the problem the
issue i get i think the problem is noble
that
there's a whole bunch of people who
don't agree about those issues so like
to get left and right working together
on health care you would have to get
some of those people agreeing on what
the solution is and they mostly don't to
get left and right working on student
loan forgiveness you would have to get
people on left and right in agreement on
on forgiving student loans we we just
don't have that right now there's
actually unfortunately very little
overlap on many of those issues
there is one issue that i keep seeing
overlap almost entirely between the left
and the right and that is corruption
itself
uh you know you're not wrong but the way
in which they want to tackle the see
here's the problem on the corruption
problem right now
the right has no interest in holding the
trump administration accountable for its
rampant corruption and there's really no
way for the right to join the left
against corruption right now without it
going squarely against so many members
of the trump administration that's a
disincentive for the right to act on the
corruption issue right now
for now yes but for the rest of congress
most the right hates congress yes
the house and the senate and that's it
more so democrats than republicans and
admittedly mostly republicans who don't
follow trump certainly certainly listen
i wish that what you're suggesting was
more plausible it feels implausible
right now i hope that changes
yeah now here's my second question
i see a golden opportunity for people to
run for congress because right now it
doesn't take a lot of effort just to
beat republicans and democrats and if
people if ordinary people were to run
against these people
why um how do you how do you think um
how well do you think ordinary people
would do against incumbents like
like blue dog republican and democrats
and republicans in all congress so
i want to see i want to see it i'm with
you that i want to see it statistically
the candidate who raises more money wins
and it is tough for random everyday
people to raise anywhere near the money
that an incumbent would raise but i do
want to absolutely see more of it noble
from salt lake city thank you so much
for the call we're going to take a quick
break
and then we will be back with more of
your calls so if you're standing by to
talk to me don't hang up we'll be right
back to it in a moment
let's get back to discord and hear from
more of you for the first time in 2022
you can find the discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go next to
pablo from albuquerque new mexico pablo
you're on the air
okay
um
so uh i was calling in um can you hear
me yes i can what's your what's on your
mind today sorry about that
um
uh i was calling uh because
you know how it's fairly common now for
uh republicans to say that they're
a little l uh libertarian
yeah as a way of kind of distancing
themselves from like a more
libertarians from the libertarian party
yeah
yeah
um
do you think that would be something
that
uh democrats could do as a way of like
sort of
like let's say saying
oh yeah i'm uh
you know
uh
like i'm trying to figure out how
exactly to phrase it like uh the bull
moose party was a fairly progressive
party
uh so
would there be a way that people could
be like oh yes uh i'm a small d democrat
as a way of kind of
um
yeah i don't think so because the
difference is that when people talk
about being democrats i know that
there's this idea of just i'm for
democracy but that's it doesn't have the
same meaning like for example i as a
progressive
tend to be what you might call small l
libertarian on a lot of different issues
and that my preference is if there's not
a good reason for government to be
involved i don't need government
involved however i draw that line very
differently than right-wing libertarians
okay so so it there's some sort of
coherence there
small d democrat doesn't really make
sense because it's sort of a confusing
term
i think that there's probably some other
way to describe being i mean listen when
i say
i am a
libertarian leaning progressive
uh or sometimes i even say i'm an
anti-authoritarian
progressive because there are kind of
revolutionary leftists that are much
more authoritarian i feel like i'm not
using partisan terms to describe things
but um i don't know i think that uh i
think i don't know that small d democrat
really makes sense to be totally frank
with you
no i i understand i'm just again you
know just thinking about it you're
thinking out loud i love it i love it
yeah
um all right i think that's it all right
thanks so much pablo from albuquerque
new mexico great to hear from you a lot
of very good questions today
uh what let's see why don't we go next
to um
there's just so many interesting people
let's just try let's just try
tom from green bay once more tom are you
are you able to unmute yourself in chat
now
wow that's really too bad
really too bad
let's try oz from kentucky oz from
kentucky you're on the air this isn't dr
oz is it
no no he's stealing my uh he's robbing
my name how's it going dave can you hear
me i can hear you fine oz
great it's been so long since i got to
talk to you know it was uh
a pre-pandemic last time i spoke to you
so is that true it's been that long
i'm a little nervous right now because i
wasn't expecting to
be on the air here um you're doing great
what's on your mind dogs
well a lot of things so since the last
time i talked you know the pandemic and
everything's it's horrible for everybody
and particularly it was hard for me i
lost my grandma i'm sorry to hear that
it was a nursing home casualty here in
kentucky and
so it was a hard time especially for
people like me who are alcoholics and i
was a binge for quite a while but i'm
sober again
that's fantastic how how long have you
been sober
well it's been about a month and a half
which that's that's great us i'm so glad
to hear that
thank you and um yeah i've got mental
health treatment that i've needed too
that you know
i was homeless for years yeah and uh
i used to live in california and i moved
back to kentucky because i got tired
tired of dealing with the wildfires
there
i used to
work on them as because i'm a i work in
forestry
i used to i'm a community organizer now
but um okay
so much stuff like you know i haven't
talked to you the george all the racial
justice pro and police brutality
protests you know i got shot during a
protest in cincinnati you you were shot
at or you actually got shot
with rubber bullets pretty much almost
uh i'm probably like 10 feet away on
purpose i had my hands up and they shot
they were trying to shoot me in the
crotch they shot me in the leg so a
rubber bullet hit your leg what how how
injured were you
i turned my thigh black and blue i've
got pictures of it but uh oh my gosh did
you need i mean does that require
treatment
i didn't i didn't get any treatment for
it healed okay but wow and pepper
sprayed i mean pepper balled and stuff
too got hit with those but uh
really all this stuff i haven't talked i
mean
the whole thing
as soon as trump got elected i knew i
was
mortified because i i've lived around
those people you know like skinheads and
nazis i've been in prison before i know
how they think unfortunately and
when he was elected
i just saw like these people these are
neo-confederates they're they're clan
their
nazis their and they want to overthrow
the government they won a civil war i
knew it back then so i was this whole
during his whole presidency i was just
in constant meltdown
and then when the january 6 happened i
was just
you know
it was i mean i have
ptsd and all kinds of stuff so seeing
that i was in the military too i wasn't
in combat but i was in the marines and
so just seeing all that stuff happen
just was so traumatic yeah like it was
it just made it so much harder to get
sober i finally did and um i lost you
know a lot of family were lost to q anon
like almost my entire family just
because some of them have kind of come
out of it but like my dad he's a truck
driver so he listens to like oan all day
and on in his truck dear god
well listen
i can't tell you how glad i am to hear
that you're six weeks sober i'm glad
that uh you know the rubber bullet
you you seem to be doing all right
and uh i hope that you know we've got
we've got better times ahead i'm gonna
let you go because we have so many
people waiting to chime in but it's
great to hear from you oz
let's go next
to eli from texas eli you're on the air
hello david cameron yes i can
okay yeah i was wondering why we haven't
seen any news on like uh
immigration lately like uh
because i believe
uh by the interests expect that obvious
administration just expanded uh trump
error
policies what what what what trump era
policies did biden expand i have um
i forgot what it was i think it was the
state state in mexico policy where it's
like uh i think these the
immigrants seeking uh
refuge or um that may be i mean listen i
can't speak to that because i i've just
gotten back from a break and i it's i
just have not been following it recently
i think you're pointing to something
really important
the reason we haven't heard much from
republicans about the disastrous job joe
biden is doing on the border is because
republicans have been busy criticizing
joe biden for other things including the
pandemic vaccine mandates
cancel culture and the like and as you
and i probably would agree
uh republicans started criticizing joe
biden on the border
immediately when he became president
even when he had not changed anything at
that point relative to what donald trump
was doing and we knew all along that it
was just a bad faith effort to hurt joe
biden's approval rating which it did it
worked i mean congratulations to them it
worked but now they've moved on to a
different shiny object and i do expect
that if the pandemic abates they're
going to go right back to immigration
because
i mean i don't i don't feel like like i
don't have confidence in either party
mm-hmm uh but i'm just wondering like do
you really think uh the black
administration is just gonna do anything
about it i don't think the biden
administration is gonna do anything
dramatic on immigration no and so that's
that's a reason to criticize them but
it's also a reason to understand that
the right-wing criticisms that say that
he's going completely 180 degrees
different than trump are just lies
yeah
i mean yeah that's true yeah
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call important i mean yeah the
the republicans got tired of immigration
they moved on to other things and that's
where we are uh
that that's where we are right now they
may get back to it you know the when
there's an election coming up
fox news stories about migrant caravans
become uh very very popular we've seen
that before let's go to louie from new
brunswick which new brunswick are you
calling from louie
hey david um this is new brunswick new
jersey actually love it what's going on
there
all right well i want to ask you a
question there's um
there's some diseases that affect
certain people groups
uh historically so for example sickle
cell
might affect african americans more
tay sachs might affect
oh
what would you say
jews um
jewish people i guess you could say are
people from middle eastern descent is
that correct am i correct and say that
tay sachs is absolutely one that is uh
more prevalent in the
ashkenazi jewish community i don't know
about sephardic but yes point taken
so what i want to say is that
is trumpism
like a spiritual disease that affects
white americans more than others
i don't think there's any genetic basis
for it i think it's a cultural basis um
i i love your framing of the question
because we're thinking of trumpism as a
disease and that that's really
interesting but
um i think it's it's more of a uh
cult-like cultural
thing
and a cultural disease it's a cultural
disease exactly right so i think that it
happens to afflict more white people
for cultural reasons not for genetic
reasons
of course i saw something really
interesting i went for christmas i went
to um for christmas break
i went down to the maryland area and we
went to a mall with the family
and i noticed something really strange
um
people who were wearing masks in the
mall and there wasn't a mandate i guess
it was voluntary okay but we're almost
entirely non-white i'm talking about
like african-americans latino americans
masking up whereas the uh the white
americans like almost no mask and my
entire family noticed it we're
from new jersey as i mentioned before
and it was just really really shocking
so what did it mean what did you take
from it what did what what what was your
takeaway
well
you know we we had a lively discussion
about what it all meant and
um i i it really boiled down to what we
thought was entitlement
like we have the freedom not to wear a
mask
uh you know i didn't have any like
discussions with anybody uh head-on or
anything this is just you know
speculation but it was it was really
prevalent like everyone noticed it from
my family so i thought that was pretty
interesting
louis you raised some fascinating
questions i appreciate you calling in
today
all right take care all right there's
louis from new brunswick wow that is
that is quite a call
all right everybody that's gonna do it
for calls today i'm so glad i got to
speak to many of you i know i didn't get
to speak to everybody but we will have
another opportunity we'll take a quick
break and be right back
all right let's get into the first
mailbag of 2022. we took a week off from
the mailbag last year i'm sorry last
week the the final week of 2021 we took
the week off from the mailbag
um actually we took a week off from the
mailbag the previous week too because i
was traveling so we have the first
mailbag of 2022 that's the point you can
email info davidpakman.com don't abuse
it
probably close to 100 people now send
emails so regularly that the emails are
auto filtered into a very specific
folder kept only
for law enforcement purposes in case law
enforcement comes to us and says sir
have you ever heard from this person and
we say yes we have um okay let's get to
a variety of different messages and
emails that came in first one is from
someone who goes by the name gypsy soul
who says who do you think you're
you're not a journalist
just a wannabe youtube star
i i never i never call myself a
journalist that's true
youtube star is more subjective but
we're in the top half of one percent of
youtube make of that what you will
not everyone refusing the vaccine is a
trump support supporter you uneducated
clown
that's true we never said that we
explained that trump supporters are the
most anti-vaxx group but not every trump
supporter is anti-vaxx so far we agree a
lot of pejoratives but we agree you're
spreading misinformation and
conspiracies and lies
well that's i reject that that's a claim
made without evidence if you want to
present some evidence i will examine it
take your vax and booster and shut your
mouth well no i do a show where i
comment
you don't have to listen i'm allowed to
speak see that's the thing about that's
the thing about freedom of speech
you can't tell me to shut my mouth you
can tell me not to listen you can tell
me you're not going to listen and that's
fine
mind your own business
your discrimination
and bullying and pushing and shaming
unvaccinated people
and we are tired of it all right well
have a good time i hope everything goes
really really well for you and uh i'm
finding myself without uh too much else
to say to this individual but that's
daily that's daily guys dozens of
messages like that here's a really weird
one i don't know if this is meant to be
hate mail
if this is meant to be
confusing or some kind of commentary but
sean wrote to me and simply said david
sir
i've
ermectin
[Music]
that's the way it's spelled
i don't know what the hell sean is
talking about
but this is a really strange job i have
where that's
part of my job is interpreting messages
like that
and trying to figure out what does it
mean all right now let's get on to more
substantive stuff nigel wrote in and
says hey david
new internal poll out from georgia 14
marjorie taylor green's district shows
marjorie with a strong lead in the
republican primary
this can't bode well for our country
best regards sir yeah you know
we've been saying one of the big signals
we're looking at in 2022 and this this
2022 is about to start we've got a few
weeks before it starts
one of the signals we'll be looking at
in terms of the country is does trumpism
do well in november
or does trumpism fail in november
and we're not going to know the answer
for some time but one of the important
things to remember is that a lot of
these weaponized trumpists marjorie
taylor greene lauren beaubert or bo bear
as uh ro khanna called her
madison cawthorne and others
they are in such heavy republican
districts and heavy trump districts
that their victories don't tell us that
much it's like they're obviously going
to win if they get uh if they run for
re-election and marjorie taylor-green is
one of those people
i expect her to win and honestly
being banned from twitter being kicked
off of her committee assignments all of
this sort of stuff i don't think it
hurts her at all with the people voting
for her in her district so yeah marjorie
taylor green is doing really really well
and i expect her to win that's not what
will tell us
will trumpism prevail long-term in the
united states
next message is from jade about
california gas prices jade says
hi david i keep hearing you refuting
trump's claims that california gas
prices have reached seven something
while presidents don't control gas
prices and it's not widespread there are
in fact many gas stations along the
california coast specifically in the big
sur
area south of monterey that have gas
prices in that range the reason being
it's just so difficult to get gas to
this area attached is a photo of a
valero and my wife and i stopped at that
my wife and i stopped that in september
when we got married showing gas between
6 59 and 7. just wanted to clear it up
big fan thank you for reading yeah
remember
i never claimed when trump would say
the lie from trump was not
that one gas station might have had gas
for 777 that was the highest number
trump picked maybe 787 he even said
the deception was trump was saying when
i left office gas was 1.87
and now it's 777 in california and
there's like five lies in there one it
wasn't 187 when he left it was more like
220 something
two
that's the national average gas price
and he's comparing it to the highest
possible price that he that maybe exists
somewhere in california for super
premium so you're not even comparing
apples to apples the apples to apples
would be that when trump said
it was 777 in california the national
gas price was like three something
that's the deception and i was just out
in california 659 is the most i saw so
it's not that these things can't exist
anecdotally
it's that um
trump's lying about the entire context
and telling you well it's it used to be
187 now it's 777 it's like it's not 777
that's not the average california price
and that's not the average national
price and it wasn't 187 when you left
and it had nothing to do with you okay i
think we get the point
drew wrote in about testing problems
covet testing problems and says hey
david i like your assessment of the
under testing that will take place but
to add to the reason why why testing
numbers will be short i live in
pittsburgh next pcr availability is 1 to
22. this is like a week old email and
there are not rapid tests the testing
infrastructure just isn't there right
now it's insane how bad the testing
infrastructure is in the united states
it's we're two years in even blue states
i just saw
friends in boston
with a picture
where they're like a block and a half
away from a street light
and they said
you have to get to that street light
just to like check in and start the
process to get a pcr test it's hours
and then it can take two to three days
to get your results
should we be testing of course
if you're not super sick
should you go to the er for a test we're
being told no because then we're cl
people are clogging up the ers so people
go elsewhere
but the diagnostic value
diminishes
if you can't get the test for this long
if you're in lines potentially spreading
it to other people in line
and at the end of the day if you don't
know sooner
you know sure everybody should isolate
until their results but it's it's just
this is not plausible
if we are saying this is the way we're
going to stop the spread testing that is
this disastrous is just not going to
stop the spread it's unclear testing
will stop the spread at all when many
people have no no symptoms and have no
reason to go get tested that's a
different issue
but it is insane that two years in
we still don't have appropriate
infrastructure in one of the richest
countries in the world
will wrote in and said how are
monoclonal antibodies more natural than
vaccines david sir have you noticed the
glaring contradiction at the heart of
the right's grift over monoclonal
antibodies being a safer alternative to
vaccine they promote vaccine hesitancy
on the grounds that they're risky
unnatural and untested but in what
universe is a vaccine which essentially
trains your own immune system to fight
off the virus on its own
less natural
than having lab produced synthetic
antibodies injected into your
bloodstream not to mention we've been
using vaccines a lot longer than we've
been using monoclonal antibodies so the
idea that vaccines are somehow
less tested doesn't make sense either
yeah guys every talking point
i
last time i talked about this people
emailed saying why are you against
monoclonal antibodies i'm not but you
take those when you're sick i'd rather
people not get sick in the first place
or if they get sick for it to be so mild
you wouldn't go and get monoclonal
antibodies
they say well the vaccine's untested and
anyway we have a treatment called
monoclonal antibodies pfizer vaccine is
fully approved monoclonal only eua well
the vaccine is big pharma it's a cash
cow for big pharma
a vaccine regimen is really really cheap
really cheap there's a lot more money to
be made on monoclonal antibodies it's
thousands of dollars per treatment so
the big pharma money grubbing thing
out the window number three side effects
from the vaccine
look at the side effects from the
antibodies hundreds of millions of
people have taken the vaccine whereas a
very very small fraction of that have
taken the antibodies the side effects
can be real and it can also affect your
immune system and its ability to fight
covet in the future
um
all of the natural i'd rather have
natural immunity so i'll get sick and
then get monoclonal antibodies there's
nothing natural about monoclonal
antibodies every argument is is not a
valid argument should we have both yes
but it's better for people not to get
sick and not need monoclonal antibodies
it's such a simple idea and yet we can't
seem to get people to accept it
benjamin wrote in and said this is a
beautiful seinfeld quote it's not a lie
if you believe it
benjamin says hello david sir hope
you're able to recognize i go to umass
amherst i know you're an alum thought
that was worth pointing out of course go
minutemen my question plain and simple
can be summed up from the quote by
george costanza in seinfeld remember
jerry it's not a lie if you believe it
i'm wondering while we're able to truly
tell trump and the rights lies from the
real truth are they truly lying if they
either a get a piece of information that
gives them the best info to prove their
argument or b
truly believe what they're saying is
true is that lying or just being stupid
i hope the question is worded clearly
enough go minutemen ben yeah um
there's no doubt that a ton of the
people repeating covet disinformation
don't believe that they are lying
they believe that they're telling the
truth
uh they're misinformed
they are in many cases incompetent
um many of them
want to believe
the things that they believe so they're
not also
you know
if i want to believe that the vaccine
doesn't work
and i find people telling me that who i
believe are credible
i will accept it with less rigor and
testing then i might if it's something i
don't want to believe so it can be a
blend of the two i'm going to accept and
believe things that i already am
predisposed to want to believe that's
certainly a part of it
but there is no question that many of
the people falling for this stuff
do believe it they may not even know how
to separate truth from fiction right
they may not really understand what does
it mean to research a topic
but they do believe it and they're not
they're not just spreading this
information on purpose they're spreading
disinformation but they're spreading it
because they believe it's true
um eden eden wrote in about 2024 and
says hey david long time listener and
member for a few years now just
interested to hear your opinion on a
warren buddha judge ticket warren is
progressive with a great track record
boot edge edge is much more corporate
but charismatic love to hear your
thoughts keep up the great work um
warren butterjudge is an interesting
ticket because
if you look at it piece by piece is
elizabeth warren the most progressive no
but is she one of the most progressive
democrats in the senate yes
wealth tax
wealth tax is something it's quite
aggressive and there's a lot of
progressives who love it she's one of
the few people who likes the wealth tax
she the most progressive on every issue
no but she has some an economic ideas
many of her ideas are quite progressive
in the senate in the senate pete buda
judge
is he the most progressive absolutely
not absolutely not but
is he at least theoretically the type of
charismatic figure he goes on fox news
and just crushes them absolutely crushes
them
energy and youth which is lacking in
much of the democratic party
yeah he fits that bill as well
and yet
with a lot of so-called progressives as
you if you said what about warren
butterjudge they would say oh that is a
toxic corporate
pro-business that's horrible horrible
horrible do i think it's a dream ticket
no
do i think that it actually when you
when you take a motion out of it
and you say what have we had
what were hillary's views
what are trump's views what are the
mainline republican views what are the
mainline democratic views and you say
here's warren's perspective and bootage
and here's the kind of intangibles
she's not very charismatic at all
buddha judge very much so
it's an interesting ticket it is not a
dream ticket it is not the uber
progressive ticket but it is an
interesting ticket and what sort of
pains me a little bit
is that a huge part of the left would
reflexively say absolutely not because
they hate both of those folks as
individuals and that uh that saddens me
i'm not calling for war and buddha judge
it's not super exciting to me
but
i do think that when we look at these
we really have to take a step back take
emotion out of it and say
let's look at policy let's put it on
paper
and see exactly where these people would
fall i think it's an interesting idea by
the way i have no idea what the best
democratic ticket would be in 2024 not
even thinking about that yet not even
thinking about that yet the first
question is is joe biden running for
re-election
um because if he is
nobody's gonna challenge him and that
that's for better or worse i've said i
don't love biden's chances in 2024
against trump i don't love biden's
chances in 2024 against someone like ron
desantis but if biden runs for
re-election i don't believe anyone's
seriously gonna try to take it away from
him let me know your thoughts we have a
great bonus show for you today it's
actually me on today's friday bonus show
pat is out this week he'll be back next
week we will see you on the bonus show
sign up at join pacman.com and get
yourself instant access